do you remember where you were when you
made that actual decision to say okay
it's time for me to step back yeah well
I was actually with foster I was do with
David I went to go see him at his
apartment
and he asked me he just asked me how I
was doing and I told him the whole story
and and I said he said man you're gonna
you think coming back cuz you know he
retired yeah and and I said you know
David the only way I could even think
about coming back as as if there was no
drama I just don't want to work that
hard I don't I want it to be joy pure he
I want this to be have musicality in
humanity and you know I just wanted to
be bliss I kept using that word I just
wanted to be bliss every day I want to
show up with people I love doing what I
love and he looked at me and he said man
that's the only way that I would really
go back into the studio he said if it
was like that and we never said it but I
know because we've talked about it many
times since yeah but I think it was a
kind of little spark we both looked at
each other come on we're doing it I want
to get back in the pen together
musically speaking of course what with
Foster's recent engagement to American
Idol alum katharine McPhee do you know
people don't know this but I know
there's news about Katherine yes but
you're his first love people don't know
that I was almost as fifth listen I love
that man so much that I have only always
wanted to be just like a foster child no
late though I'm so glad I got to use
them yeah you did you finally threw that
in there and they get just me
nobody up nobody
so the album it's complete you said it's
completely does it have a title when to
make spec I mean everybody's hungry for
some music sure hope so yeah
it doesn't have a title I have ideas I
call it bliss yeah maybe not very much
but you're still working on Alexa T play
bliss yeah listen my manager my record
company they showed me who I they are
who I thought they were you know they no
one ever brought a word up to me about
working or or contracts or shows booked
every single day was a message from the
president of my record company saying I
love you thinking about you praying for
you my manager saying you know you know
I'm with Bryan Adams on the road here at
Jann Arden and and you know they just
send their love and nothing never I
never felt a an iota of pressure there's
a great sense of of team and family and
like we're doing this this isn't me
coming back it's us coming back you know
we built we built this thing and it's
gonna be a blast for us to all be able
to celebrate it together and actually be
in the moment enough to celebrate it
yeah
then you also are getting a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
mm-hmm that sort of unbelievable yeah
that's really cool that's just on the
flip side of all this then a cool just a
cool bit yeah you get this listen it's a
wonderful I have to say all the things
I'm supposed to say what a wonderful
humbling I'm you know but compared to
the gifts that you were given this is a
thing it's like yes I get that
definitely I don't know what to say yeah
I'm so happy I mean how cool was that
but in the scheme of things it's it's
very cool
yes but great we have your whole family
their whole families both families
coming that's fantastic
that's unbelievable